the human toll of conflict thousands of
people have left their homes in southern
Lebanon along the border with
Israel schools now shelters for those
with nowhere else to go 8,000 children
left without
education many have lived through a
similar situation before some more than
once we lived under Israeli occupation
we've been displaced in previous Wars
our homes have been destroyed we really
have nothing look where we are
now this escalation and fighting is the
most serious since the last war between
Israel and Hezbollah in
2006 local officials say they are
preparing for the worse nearly 100 km of
the Border region is now a military zone
at least 2 km deep but those living
further inside Lebanon are also starting
to to
move we are in an emergency situation so
far there are 6,000 displaced people in
one Governor alone they couldn't bring
anything with them we need to find
blankets and beds since winter is
approaching in recent days the frequency
and intensity of hezbollah's attacks
against Israeli military positions have
increased and so has Israel's response
lebanon's prime minister says he is
working to prevent the war in Gaza from
spreading to his country but the state
has little say over the more powerful
armed group Hezbollah which says it is
in the heart of the battle and if needed
it is ready to get more
involved that could mean a larger Exodus
officials have condemned Israel for its
attacks on Gaza but with Lebanon already
grappling with one of the world's worst
Financial collapses many fear it won't
be able to handle a full-blown
War
the needs are great and we have few
resources we all know the state of
municipalities and Ministries that is
why we appeal to local and international
organizations to provide us with
help Israel is threatening strikes of
unimaginable magnitude and Devastation
if Hezbollah enters the war on Gaza many
here remember the 2006 War when Israel
leveled villages in South Lebanon and
repeatedly targeted the southern suburbs
of the capital where Hezbollah
supporters live but the Iranian back
group is equally defiant zanah aljaz
Southern
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz